okay well I did not get the job in New
York but I got the real prize domestic
bliss Jan made me breakfast this morning
well she bought the milk it's soy this
is why I do it
that's what I have to come home to she
probably won't be up for a few hours
this is going to be a very good year
very good Jan is at home Jim is back my
protege Ryan is a corporate good stuff
Andy and Dwight are rocking the sales
team I feel very blessed
I told Dwight that there is honor and
losing which as we all know is
completely ridiculous but there is
however honor in making a loser feel
better which is what I just did for
Dwight would I rather be feared or loved
easy both I want people to be afraid of
how much they love me and I think I
proved that today at the dojo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me walking Phyllis down the aisle was
supposed to be the highlight of the
wedding and now the wedding has no
highlight
[Music]
I can't believe I pushed that that guy's
lazy ass around all day
I'll tell he was ready to stand up and
steal the show that's well I Got News
for You Albert that's your real name
shows not over
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
your brands have been doing great lately
and your sales staff is reporting very
strong numbers outperforming last year
in fact and I don't know exactly how to
put this but what are you doing right
right what Utica Albany all the other
branches are struggling but your branch
is reporting strong numbers look you're
not our most traditional guy but clearly
something you are doing is right and I
just I need to get a sense of what that
is David here it is my philosophy is
basically this and this is something
that I live by and I always have and I
always well don't ever for any reason do
anything to anyone for any reason ever
no matter what no matter where or who or
who you are with or or where you are
going or or where you've been ever for
any reason whatsoever
sometimes I'll start a sentence and I
don't even know is going I just hope I
find it along the way like an improv
conversation an improvisation Oh what
are you doing here we came here to eat
dinner unto party this is a dinner party
right what is he doing here
yes what are you doing here Dwight is my
friend we weren't invited
you said that I could not invite Dwight
because he was not part of a couple and
because we didn't have enough wine
glasses
Dwight brought glasses and a person so
whatever you want just like always
whatever you whatever I want it's never
whatever I want what I wanted to see
stopped and you wanted to see Wicked
what did we see so when I said that I
wanted to have kids and you said that
you wanted me to have a vasectomy what
did I do when you said that you might
want to have kids and I wasn't so sure
reversed and then when you said you
definitely didn't wanna have kids who
are refers back
snip snap snip snap snip snap I did
you've no idea the physical toll the
three vasectomies have a person and I
bought this condo to fill with children
I'm so sorry that I don't want to bring
kids into this screwed-up world okay but
larger you want to have kids than fine
you win Darrell you are a good worker
and a good man I just you know times are
tight now I just don't think corporates
going to go for this right now are you
wearing lady clothes what are you
wearing lady clothes they look like lady
pants no this is a power suit that
there's a woman suit I do not buy
women's clothes would not make that
mistake again
okay Pam would you please tell Darryl
that this is not a woman suit
oh my god that's a woman suit you're
wearing a woman suit no I do I I wear
men's suits okay I got this out of a
pimp who makes it um mysterious it is
mysterious because the buttons are on
the wrong side that's the mystery
shoulder parents you see that way okay
would you stop it please
Oh none of that tipped you off it's
European okay it's a European cut
Michael the pants don't have any pockets
no they don't see Italians don't wear
pockets it's been a really rough couple
of days
this helps a little hey maybe you want
to come over and read my closet no I
don't want to do that because I'm twice
your size anyway yeah you look like
Hillary Clinton um let's just do this in
15 okay can you stay like that for one
second I got some emails negotiations
are all about controlling things about
being in the driver's seat and make one
tiny mistake you're dead I make one tiny
mistake I wore woman's clothes Phyllis
you're a wonderful woman and you're a
hell of a bowler Cheers
Thank You Randy that was great
thank you thank you very much hi I'm
Michael Scott and for the next 40
minutes I am going to be your tour guide
through the lives of Phyllis lapin and
Bob Vance one of the great seemingly
impossible love stories of our time my
name is Michael Scott Webster's
dictionary defines wedding as the fusing
of two metals with a hot torch will you
know something I think you guys are two
metals gold medals for those of you who
don't know me I'm Michael Scott
Phyllis his boss to quote from The
Princess Bride manwich the most
important part of a speech is the
opening line and when time is not a
factor I like to try out three or four
different ones Phyllis and Bob they're
celebrity couple name would be flop you
look at her and she's kind of matronly
today but back in high school I swear
her nickname was Easy Rider
now as for Bob Bob Vance okay that's a
guy thanks but give me works okay
holding hold on
look look I didn't say anything
what Phyllis is dad upstaged me at the
ceremony and I think you owe me this
okay
give me the microphone now I'm not gonna
Mike okay okay okay
you